عندما يصنف الفيروس التاجي
بما سيراه الكثير من الناس هو
اسم عنصري ، إنه أمر محرج جدًا ،
نعم إنه جيد إنه ذئب ، اسمح لي
أنه لقب عنصري وسماعه
يخرج من أفواه الرئيس
الولايات المتحدة أمر مخزٍ
، واسمحوا لي أن أعود خطوة للوراء للحظة
التي تواجه فيها الأمة أعظم الأزمات
ربما في التاريخ الأمريكي الحديث ،
لديك الوباء ولديك
قضايا العرق التي
تحاول الدولة معالجتها في نفس الوقت
الوقت والرئيس يصل أخيرًا إلى
المنصة لإلقاء خطاب أمام
الشعب الأمريكي وأنصاره ولكن في
محاولة لجلب المزيد من المؤيدين قد
يفكر المرء وما الذي يفعله يستخدم
الصفات العنصرية للحديث عن كوبا قال إنه
لا ينبغي لنا '  قال إنه لإجراء المزيد من الاختبارات ،
أعتقد أن الاقتباس هو أنه أخبر
شعبه بإبطاء الاختبار على Kovach ، كان الأمر
كما لو كان الذئب
يحاول السخرية من kovat بطريقة ما كان
يحاول أن يكون فنانًا هناك
على  س  Tage وقضى 20 دقيقة
في مسيرته في ذلك المنحدر في West Point
كما لو أن الجمهور الأمريكي
يركز حقًا على أن الجمهور الأمريكي يريد هذه الأيام
أن يسمع كيف يريد هذا الرئيس
إخراج البلاد من الحفرة
التي توجد فيها وبدلاً من ذلك  هذا ما
كان يستمع إليه الشعب الأمريكي
الليلة
، وأعتقد بصدق أنه من المعيب
أن الرئيس لم يتمكن من النهوض
والتحدث إلى البلاد حول المشاكل التي
نواجهها وكيف يحاول إصلاحها.